gió anh rộng hoàn liệu bảo số ba kết hợp dạy hội tụi giết đối, khu vực bắt chúng bộ,
đặc biệt là thành hóa và nghị ăn, thì tục hứng chiếc vừa lớn kéo dạy đến hết ngày 20a tháng bẩy.
Lộn ngơ trong những ngày qua tại nhiều nơi vượt 8.000 mết, như sầm sơn, thành hóa,
1.7000 mết tạm, 1 lống, nghị ăn, 1.8000 mết.
Người lớn cây lũ lịch sử trên sông cả, 1 nước tại trạm mường sánh, nghị ăn,
1 lúc 1 dường ngày 20a tháng bẩy đặt 1,5% mết, vượt 1 lũ lịch sử khu vệ bốn mết,
tại trạm thạm lũ vượt được lịch sử tối 1 vệ 8 mết.
Tình đến ngày 20a tháng bẩy, thin thay đặc khiến bà người thiệt mạc 1 người mất tích 5 người bị thường.
Tại nghị ăn, hơn bà nghịnh bẩy trạm tảm mấy nhà dân bị ngập,
hàng trăm mùa nhà ở cả 2 tình bị tốc mái hư học.
Giờ thông nhiều nơi bị chiếc cách sò sạch lợt, sống ngày 30a, tình hóa và 1 chăm tri mấy sảo điểm tại nghị ăn.
Dự báo, từ ngày 20a tháng bẩy, khi dài hội tụi nhìn đối xí yếu, vùng thấp 6 phi tây hỏa đậu trở lại
bác bộ và bác trụ bộ sẽ chuyển sang thời tiết nặng nắm.
Chào khi đó, tên nhìn và nặng bộ vẫn tiếp tục có mưa dông và chữ tối dơ so aso mùa tây nàng hỏa đậu mại.